i'm felicia Leatherwood sharing my kit
essentials with ET style so what we have
here are my favorite things like
honestly i cannot operate without these
tools first of all we have the felicia
Leatherwood detangler brush and i love
this brush because it moves with the
hair so you don't lose hair it helps to
actually detangle your hair all the way
from the ants to the roof so this is my
favorite especially when the hair is
like wet and you're doing deep
conditioning wash and go with a is great
the next thing and I talked about this I
talked about this often actually this
here is actually a beard brush but I use
it on the edges so it's kind of like a
really fabulous toothbrush and I
remember in high school we actually
would take an old toothbrush and kind of
like put a little gel on it with the
edges down but since the scub Rings this
incredible next we have the nylon
ponytail holders okay so what this does
this makes it easy for you to slip it
off your hair when you want your hair to
be loose foot out grabbing hair a lot of
times we tend to use ponytail holders
that will angle the hair around it and
then you end up breaking the hair we
don't want that so the nylon ponytail
holder on my best friend this is a
velvet hair pin and if you were rocking
natural hair and you don't want the pin
to be shiny in the hair and I do a lot
of red carpet stuff so sometimes when
you use these pins you can see the shine
when the flash goes off but with the
velvet it actually blends very well into
the hair and it looks like here so the
velvet hair pins that I love are from
French cheese this is the best-kept
secret so this is by French cheese and
it's the velvet hairpin then I have the
color track hair clips I love these it
absolutely will hold a hair in place
without making an indentation on the
hair and
and of course my Chi blow-dryer
so what makes this blow-dryer so great
for me as a hairstylist is that a lot of
times I don't actually use the handle
it's better to just go ahead and grab it
by the nose and so I get the blow-dryer
that doesn't have the handles because I
don't need it and so basically I hold it
this way and you can get a better grip
and blow-dry your hair and then I have
my eye on diffuser so check this out
this actually pops out so you can travel
with this a lot of times women they'll
go to the gym their hair will be wet
some women wear weaves and that hold a
lot of moisture or if you have locks and
you need to dry the hair you're doing a
washing goal you want to try to hear but
you don't want to move or disturb the
actual texture or the curl so you use
the diffuser and you can pop it flat and
pop it in your purse or your backpack
and keep going so this is my other
best-kept secret this is a terry cloth
towel and this actually helps you to
keep your hair hydrated after you have
washed your hair shampooed and
conditioned it you want to keep the hair
moisturize and you want to keep the
hydration and fight the hair so the
terry cloth actually helps to keep
moisture inside the cuticle layers of
your hair whereas a regular towel will
extract the moisture out and cause your
hair to be dry now if you don't have a
terry cloth towel you can use a t-shirt
an old t-shirt will still do the trick
and you will notice a huge difference
but what I have to take with me on the
road is this unchic e so okay this is
the curl box this is the coconut curling
jelly
and they use black scenes to actually
make their gels which I love doesn't
make the hair all crispy and hard now
creams alright for my four C's out there
I love this right here this is curls
blueberry blitz this is the twist and
shout cream and you can get amazing
twists up with this also if you just
don't want to use chill and go ahead
soft and moisturize this right here will
definitely do the trick so this is
another one of my favorites
a lot of women say as soon as they sweat
a little bit their edges tend to curl up
this is the hair gummy gel this hair
gummy gel is incredible and you can
actually wake up the next morning re-wet
the area you use this and we activate
the product so it's great the reason why
it's in this is because it's my travel
size get the travel size tools because
what you want to do is you can find
these I guess like at any pharmacy they
have these containers and you take your
favorite products and you put them in
this so that you don't have to take this
because sometimes it will spill
everywhere or you can't go through if
you just want to carry on but this right
here makes it so much easier for those
of you out there who want a little bit
of moisture and a little shine and you
want to just complete the style after
you've actually done it I would suggest
that you use
hair polish remix by Fantasia this is
the icy hair polish of mist and it
basically has aloe vera in it we love
aloe vera and vitamin E and it becomes
the front slang for your hair so you
just a little bit and you see that it's
not heavy it's perfect and it smells
wonderful kind of smells like bubblegum
so this is what's in my arsenal these
are my favorite kit essentials I'm
curious to know what you're using